[Music]
and what the [ __ ] news submitted by I'm
gonna eat a hat it's not good for you a
twitch streamer brags about killing a
dog when she was a vet tech I read duh I
saw this on Twitter I didn't investigate
there was so there's like the streamer I
guess it's on Twitch we he interviews
like I don't know the [ __ ] G so you
can you're viewing these three girls
what I'm gonna [ __ ] are [ __ ]
conflict adventures supposed to save
lives
yeah and then he asks one girl he was
like so what's like the worst thing
you've ever done
and this [ __ ] just like um like not
just oh you know I just you want to show
them the video to show them the video
okay show me the video I need proof here
we go which which [ __ ] is it cuz what
are you wait wait are they are they game
girls I don't know okay let's go cute
what about you what's the worst thing
you've ever done to somebody oh I used
to I used to work as a veterinary
technician so I like dog like how did
she kill it
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's just say I work in a hospital
please do specifically injected yeah she
said it though
I killed the dog on purpose but the
shitty thing is he asked her do you
regret it she was like shitty dog shitty
person like this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
psychotic well she's crazy
yeah so the this person's really [ __ ]
up though like unimaginably [ __ ] up
and this dog is like all so [ __ ] up
alright could they scheme together like
this [ __ ] scams you embezzled
your money and the dog we've all seen
that dog before you know that dog that's
like you there yeah every time you take
care of this dog dollars go missing
shits in your pillowcase yeah [ __ ]
bites your ankle that's a felony felony
yeah felony yeah she really if it does
come out that she intentionally killed
this person to jail you will go to jail
there was like a witch-hunt now cuz it
was posted on reddit and it went [ __ ]
crazy and now there's people are
tweeting it and then someone's like yeah
we got into contact with the vet or the
better office or whatever which dog died
um-huh
know just where she worked oh yeah we're
know but then they're trying to
investigate which dog investigated is
figure out the story and the office said
we're in contact with the local police
station because so this [ __ ] is like
yeah and now she was going on [ __ ]
Twitter saying it's so stupid how people
can't tell whether you're a troll
alright not you would think this
community would know how to recognize a
troll when they see what she looks like
a troll but she was telling the truth
she didn't act like a troll she looked
especially when she was like can we move
past this and there she brings it up as
well I didn't kill the dog the
medication killed exactly so there's not
this
she thinks that everyone's gonna be like
oh yeah that's funny girl she has no
[ __ ] idea how far she is her moral
compass from everybody else and she's a
posh [ __ ] or logo yeah they're both
garbage one of them but I think she's
even stupider cuz I'm sure because she's
pretty she could say this [ __ ] without
any sort of repercussion but because she
said it in an open forum like twitch now
people are [ __ ] like wanna act like
drug dealers going oh my god yeah
yeah there's probably like a serial
killer just watching right now they're
like what to a dog he's probably
watching this twitch episode and [ __ ]
like I mean if these are to kill a human
than to kill a dog I know what a dog's
do people are I mean he was just I mean
dogs are just so the thing is she trying
to justify the dog killing because she
would like the owner was an [ __ ] yeah
they'd kill the [ __ ] owner and kill
the [ __ ] owner don't kill the dog
that's just so sick though like to want
to get rid of something in like you're
playing God like that's like some
next-level sick [ __ ] like I killed their
kid because the mom was the idiot I
could barely kill a [ __ ] aunt you
know I shoot and the thing if she shows
no remorse she was like no one knew
because I'm a professional exactly how
many other dogs she do she the fan she
says well people don't like people
people or dogs die all the times like
alright well you know little people die
all the time inside people die in a
hospital all the time but do you [ __ ]
work their secret murder
exactly crazy-ass [ __ ] wish you were
cat now I don't know but people don't
know that's like being a paramedic and
goofy like people always die in the
[ __ ] ambulance scientists killed them
so I'll just run people over now wait
you turned out what huh people found out
what name or something people found like
her her name where she works you know
all that because she's made sense though
say like she's a troll like she's trying
to claim she's a troll it's like
equivalent of sending a dick pic and
saying oh sorry I got hacked like you're
not you're not fooling anyone do this
[ __ ] is so interesting like I I always I
see it from this perspective of like you
know people are extremely appalled which
they should be but you know she's not
really a celebrity you know so but he's
kind of weird like they're I feel like
I'm not surprised because it's a [ __ ]
weird person yeah I mean like a
psychopath like I'm not surprised that
somebody would say that online because
these type of people they live in their
own world you know I mean I think it's
wrong yeah if you're not around other
people who are of like sane like just
like like normal intellect right they're
not exposed to that [ __ ] so that's just
like what Joe said she put that out
there like the whole you know what it
means it's like if you're not exposed to
like just normal human people and you're
just crazy
you're just a crazy at my old world but
at least I have morals [ __ ] mm-hmm like
you can see it on her face to when she
first says it she's like super kind of
confident and then the guy let's say
that she was joking right kind of joke
like oh [ __ ] there's no there's no humor
at the end of it no I don't know she's
trying to become a veterinarian herself
[ __ ] that yeah yeah you selfish [ __ ]
cuz you're supposed to take like the
Socratic oath later on right like you're
valid till they try to save anything no
matter what she's a dualistic radicals I
think so
oh wow yeah so I think they have to not
the em dog hog my name is Simone if you
[ __ ] you Simone you're piece of [ __ ] she
just wants to be like dr. Kevorkian
that's all she wants to do is like
exactly she do the doggy you said you
Shanae shush yep if this does turn out
to be true I hope you think if I can put
her away for a long time [ __ ] her dude
yeah they were so pretty all three of
them they were very I know I was like I
hope it's not you it was none of them
and then somebody was gonna pop into the
fourth box you know I mean and then it
was gonna be some other [ __ ] last night
these girls are too pretty to do stuff
like that
yes why since this is Simone look like
oh it's just way better on video the
[ __ ] is this what happened who's that
that's a girl that's not her
that's a dog killer right there she does
not look good close-up it's also a down
there's a puppy on her chest
there's our laughs oh that's all I
should kill it's a market picture so
maybe we'll give it to her no the
downward you don't want downward because
then you look fat I'm just hoping that
way no that is about that is a downward
picture though no it is but the reason
why you don't want it take is cuz you're
gonna look fatter
yeah very disturbing I just I just hope
that that was a really terrible joke and
she actually the way she reacted the way
she was talking
I'm just hoping cuz if she you know does
become a vet and then she just has a
sick sense of humor like doctors and
surgeons do that we just don't
understand would you want to take your
pets to visit I wouldn't I wouldn't risk
it
no but I'm just I'm just hoping that it
it was a it was a it was a really poor
exercise judging my pets to doctors for
[ __ ] wait what they don't need to go no
doctor I know oh god no [ __ ] pets are
animals man that made a survive dude are
you serious
no you're not you're such do you think
when yuccas gonna survive in a while ago
survive in a tire shop as she lived in a
tire she's pretty [ __ ] good she legit
lid as soon as you raise your voice you
go hey she's like missing it yeah touch
her feet at all times while she doesn't
appear as much as she used to and she's
rehabilitated yeah my dad found out that
so she doesn't she got nervous with
hands so whoever had her before was like
beating her ass she lets feet so much
it's a [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] like she I
love her defeats no beats you know what
the cool thing about my puppy is I've
never struck my puppy but because I gave
her such Stern voicing all she does I
just have to raise my voice and then she
knows she [ __ ] stuff so I got their ass
oh yeah the dad voice down
yeah I'm like hey she goes that [ __ ]
don't work out off of my dog's [ __ ] goes
woof and walks away [ __ ] I don't like
it come here you're not my real dad and
you know what what animals like give you
attitude it actually really pisses me
off because they don't they don't
understand the food chain it's [ __ ]
annoying yeah be like you know when you
go to a park and this girl comes up to
you and your little sup and it just goes
walks close of you I'm like no you're
supposed to run away who the [ __ ] do you
think Oh goose - yeah yeah those [ __ ]
jeans [ __ ] up I eat you like what the
[ __ ] man oh there's a [ __ ] ton of geese
and they just [ __ ] so there's such a
small heaven in this place called Elk
Grove Park you walk up to because when
they bite it hurts dude that music video
boy walks up to this [ __ ] geese that
wouldn't run away and he just grabbed
that [ __ ]
and he was holding a deist like a baby
bald animal dude man how did it not bite
you not he was like he was right one is
about to spread its wings and fly away I
[Laughter]
made sure he was okay have you seen the
video the little little Chinese baby
that grabs the [ __ ] pigeon by your
neck yeah before he like eats their
thing yeah oh my god yeah the best thing
is a guilty dogs when they're really
guilty tofu tofu I got mad Toby
yesterday she [ __ ] and then like she
went to hide behind the couch and I
pulled the couch out her dumb ass her
big ass ciaochao body still sticking out
but her face is under the couch stick
and she's still hiding like I seen your
dumb ass it's so cute
I
this [ __ ] gets jumped by the way
[Music]